stéphanie grammond mes chaussures j'ai
christian dufour bonsoir eaux swde
ensemble vous aurez noté que ou pas les
prendre une bière en abitibi christian
les bras sont ouverts en abitibi les
restaurants les thèmes les sont en zone
jaune donc ont honte envers s'est
tranquillement on en reparlera mais
aujourd'hui deux sujets la réforme du
delà de la loi électorale michel sait au
juste que c'est normal que l'opposition
disent écoutez l'on va prendre le temps
d'en parler parce qu'on veut ajusté
trois jours pour voter par exemple aider
d'autres mesures dans les sièges à celle
des qu'est ce qui se passe d'après vous
il se passe ce qu'il se passe
normalement quand les députés commencent
à sera content que ça ça va être pas mal
moi je dirais qu'il va être déposé avant
qu'il ya une élection je pense qu'il va
y avoir une élection se prêta mais avoir
donné un ajournement de la chambre au
mois de juin et après c'est probablement
qu'il dit ville ce seront de nouveaux
députés qui vont siéger après ça après
une élection a fait son temps alors là
pour malte où il devient difficile pour
faire adopter n'importe quel projet de
loi et l'eau bien sûr consommateurs on
sait ce que c'est favorable est ce que
ça nous est favorable
trois jours de vote d'abord du vote par
un par la poste etc
ils doivent se dire bon on va essayer de
faire porter le chapeau aux parents au
parti au pouvoir d'autant que les
numéros doit mettre le son le dernier
sondage de ce matin dix points d'avancé
conservateurs doivent être adoptées oui
mais en même temps pour les
gouvernements à adopter ce projet de loi
c'est de dire on comprend qu'un problème
avec la polémique
ok stéphane et comment vous comprenez on
va regarder le tableau la démesure en
même temps mais comment vous comprenez
le débat qui se joue à trois mais je
comprends aussi qu'il ya des élections
mais si on se souvient dans le budget
qui était déposée il ya quelques
semaines y avait quand même un cadeau de
500 $ chic qui va être envoyée au mois
d'août à tous les aînés de 75 ans et
plus
vraiment du duo électro sanou week-end
comme ce chèque le doubs on pourrait
imaginer que peut-être qu'il aurait des
élections un peu après évidemment c'est
des suppositions donc mais quand même
les libéraux sont probablement en train
d'essayer de mettre le terrain c'est
vrai que liliane entonnoir cinq semaines
avant la pause estivale donc il ya
plusieurs projets qui est qui qui essaie
de descendre ça crée un goulot
d'étranglement
mais oui effectivement avoir des mesures
sanitaires plus adapté aux élections oui
parce que sur le fond christien trois
jours pourquoi pas d'un faux nom ouais
c'est ça le problème de l'argumentaire
des partis d'opposition c'est que pas
vraiment de différence sur le fond ce
projet doit qui était avant tout
technique qui est une recommandation du
directeur général des élections
en fait les libéraux ont réussi kaki et
quelque chose au fond ils sont redonné
vol se redonner la possibilité de tenir
des élections dans un contexte qui leur
est favorable
puis comme le dit stéphanie bon dans le
jeu d'optique pour juste partisane dans
une optique d'intérêt public ce quand
même pas futile par des que la pandémie
se prolonge quand même dure plus
longtemps que prévu de s'organiser pour
tenir éventuellement des élections parce
que la vie continue donc
les libéraux se trouve à quelque chose
sous couvert d'intérêt public en partie
aux objectifs il se redonne une marge de
manoeuvre pour tenir des élections qui
veulent manifestement bon on va écouter
aujourd'hui monsieur blanchet qui
disaient non non non faut pas pousser
les règles démocratiques et répondu
monsieur leblanc et son école le
gouvernement suspend les règles de la
démocratie pour changer les règles de la
démocratie
on change pas les règles d'une partie
dehors qui au milieu de la partie si les
deux équipes sont pas d'accord alors je
ne vois aucune justification
s'il y en a eu une foudre à quelqu'un le
demandent au premier ministre pour
procéder par bâillon sur une loi
fondamentale de l'exercice de la
démocratie
c'est extrêmement inquiétant de voir le
gouvernement imposer un bouillon pour
modifier ses règles électorales en
pleine pandémie n'était pas urgent
pendant quatre mois
qu'est ce qui justifie soudainement le
boyau situe pas ce qu'ils veulent aller
en élections sereines pas de mise nous
avons cru aussi bien un bien bon de
répondre au rapport du directeur général
des élections qui a demandé au parlement
en octobre de présenter des
modifications à la loi électorale trempe
horaires pour s'assurer qu'une élection
puisse se faire dans le contexte la
pandémie et c'est ça que nous sommes en
train de faire une chasse aux journaux
l'impression que vraiment les libéraux
veulent y aller et l'opposition est pas
trop tenté la même temps vous savez
comme cela chez eux ils parlent de
carottes et de hors jeu on va utiliser
le bâillon qui location tac aux mondiaux
à ottawa pour fraport très projet de loi
c dans les règlements de la chambre soit
agréable mais c'est dans les règlements
de la chambre d'autre part les règles
fondamentales de la démocratie n'ont ni
une amende la loi électorale de façon
temporaire pour faire face à ces
militaires c'est pas dur pas grand monde
qui va trouver ça exagéré ou une info si
je peux je veux vous entendre sur deux
projets de transport en commun important
pour tout le québec
le prolongement de la ligne bleue et
leur m2 les mêmes delhaize
il ya eu beaucoup de brouhaha parce que
les gens dont on ne veut pas de portions
ou centre-ville aérienne je vous entends
je vais à temps monsieur arbaud à la
caisse responsable de l'unité de
laquelle s'occupe de se dire on peut pas
aller en souterrain pour lui c'est réglé
et par ailleurs il dit ça va être des
très silencieux en écoute pour aller de
l'est au centre de montréal on se
retrouve à croiser beaucoup d'ouvragés
certains des aqueducs
qui fonctionnent certains par gravité
donc qui sont pas des plats sable qui
sont plus que centenaires trois lignes
de métro l'a720 donc on a regardé
différentes solutions possibilités
comment faire avec différentes
techniques pour aller au centre-ville de
montréal
mais c'est vraiment ça pose énormément
d'enjeux technique
bon ça c'est sur la portion aérienne du
centre-ville tour de table ses fans du
grand monde a l'impression que le rem de
l'ess avant cela les consultations ça
commençait aujourd'hui et parallèlement
à cela la ligne bleue au pôle même
pilote dans l'avion et c'est là on nous
annonce d'autres dépassements de coûts
comment vous voyez ça m'aide à côté on a
l'impression que la ligne bleue ça va
trop lentement et sapho depuis 1979 donc
de dire que ça avance à pas de tortue
c'est bien s'est justifié et d'autre
part mais du côté du renne de l'est on a
l'impression qu'on met un peu la charrue
devant les boeufs un ou devant la reine
parce que on l'a la caisse des dépôts la
caisse et des baies cdpq un franck et sa
filiale allez y les clés du projet à des
dépouilles mois que le gouvernement il
lui a conféré elles qui sont différents
qui lui permet d'aller plus vite et
évidemment c'est le projet pour toutes
sortes de questions sur notamment la
est-ce que ça va être en plein
centre-ville alors qu'on est en train de
rabaisser les ai toutes les
infrastructures enlever le béton défaire
lit et les échanges allaient ce qu'on
veut ce que pouvait rien d'autre
les centres villes j'ai l'impression que
ça va trop vais pleurer pour par suivi
de la ligue bleue mais trop vite leurs
aises et il y en a peu de transparence
pour l'instant et et on n'a pas
nécessairement
est tous les ans on n'a pas l'impression
de toute façon que les deux projets sont
sains et mais ça c'est un enjeu parce
que dame ans est un réseau pense pas il
faut tout ça fonctionne ensemble et
c'est pas clair qu'on a ce sentiment
lancement bon michel je pense que vous
vous allez me dire vous trouvez que ça
va peut-être trop vite qui est un manque
de transparence côté du rêve mais en
même temps je vous soumets que les
projets autre projet qui ne sont pas
même que ça soit les sur pie-ix le la
voie réservée ça fait 14 ans qu'on
appelle la ligne bleue ça fait 40 ans
qu'on en parle alors de côté à la lente
à saas fee peuple de l'autre ça se fait
parce que à chaque fois que ce soit
pie-ix que ce soit la ligne bleue et un
gouvernement qui arrive qui dit oh ça va
pas jeter l affaire ça coûte trop cher
je puisse y subsister
on a tellement souvent joué dans le film
peut-être est-ce que je vous prédis que
honda abandonné le projet de ligne bleue
d'ici l'automne et on va dire regardez
le rêve lui marche et après il n'ya pas
obligé de payer mon idée zeddam
expropriations c'est parce qu'on lui
donne ses exportations la ligne de deux
montagnes
les choses sont pas comparables mais on
va essayer de les comparer et on va tuer
encore une fois la double je me souviens
pas de gouvernement
sauf peut-être celui de madame marois
qui était sérieux dans son intention de
vote soit prolongée quand vous cette
fois ils ont essayé de la tuer pour vous
ça se propose d'aller une vue je je je
je crains fort que ça ne se fasse que le
rem ils vont le bull d'oser son adresse
certes il faut bas j'ai lu attentivement
en fait le longue le long article dans
la presse sur le sujet lui-même deux
fois pour se comprendre quelque chose
ce qui reste évidemment c'est le manque
d'arrimage entre ces deux mégaprojets la
main gauche c'est pas content de ce que
fait la main droite en 6 4 est la ligne
bleue je sais pas si ça va se réaliser
ou pas mais quand même quelque chose qui
ressort beaucoup à quel point ci se
réalise l'organisation de ce projet on
nous parle de quatorze comités 14
beaucoup 14 comme telle de délais de
confusion de la direccte et il
pas de pilote dans l'avion c'est le
titre du l'article donc les quatorze
comités sont comme un peu à la dérive et
ça ramène à une de mes obsessions vous
allez me dire patrice c'est qu'au québec
le ça commence à faire beaucoup
infra structures bureaucratiques sont
pas capables de livrer la marchandise
depuis le nom de vue ce qu'elle s'était
essentiellement points
christian c'est seul que leur m
parce qu'ils sont plus efficaces parce
qu'on leur donnait à laquelle plus de
pouvoir c'est vrai en même temps ça
effraie beaucoup beaucoup de monde ya sa
va trouver mais ce projet-là ce fait
c'est comme si on avait les deux modèles
devant nous le projet si ce que
j'aimerais c'est pour ça que j'ai
critiqué la commission laurent la
semaine passée j'étais un des seul sait
que c'est bien beau les beaux sentiments
me ferai peut-être un moment donné au
québec regarder les façons de faire
regardez les façons de faire dans le
système public et parapublic passe
quelque chose qui marche pas c'est roule
la santé la protection de la jeunesse
la ligne bleue car ici le rêve c'est
peut-être trop vite moment que je monte
à que ça se fasse trop vite que ça se
fait douter la ligne bleue series que
hockey michel nature rapidement qui a
mis 14 comités sur le dos de la stm qui
devrait être le maître d'oeuvre de la
ligue bleue c'est gouvernement du québec
alors un moment donné c'est ça qui est
le problème en quand on veut noyer son
chien on dit qu'il a la rage leurs amis
14 comités chute au pontil projet la stm
le mandat de réaliser quelque chose et
qu'on lui a pas mis des bâtons dans le
métro de laval
ça a très bien marché fanni mais jalon
dans le même sens parce que c'est
sociaux si on avait donné les mêmes
moyens pour faire le développement de la
ligne bleue que les moyens qu'on a donné
à la caisse de dépôt on n'en serait pas
là en ce moment donc il ne faut pas il
faut pas comparer des pommes avec des
oranges
ce n'est pas une question de culture et
de multitudes de comités de ci-dessus cc
je m'excuse de persister mais oui c'est
en partie ducation de culture et c'est
très difficile de changer la culture est
une question qu'on peut se poser est ce
qu en dessous de seuils a pas le fait
que la ligne bleue c'est quand même dans
le domaine be nice
pala montréal valérie plantes et puis à
l'autre c'est le gouvernement du québec
de françois legault
or c'est qu'un secret de polichinelle
que madame plante jamais été capable de
s'affirmer de façon réelle face aux
gouvernements locaux je vais poser ces
questions là madame rouleau à 18h30 au
téléjournal il sera avec nous mais les
responsables du grand montréal et la
ligne bleue on verra mais celle ci si si
le mot crise est une série comme wes
première question merci à vous trois ans
à lui pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit